hey what's up guys my name is vicino
welcome back to my game engine series
it's been a while but we are back
and today we've got a bit of an exciting
episode because we're going to be
talking all about gizmos
last time i think we did like
civilization stuff check out the video
linked up there
and today as i mentioned is going to be
all about um adding in some kind of
manipulation gizmo so that we can
actually like translate rotate and scale
entities and their transforms inside our
scene by using like an on-screen gizmo
like much like
what you would see in any other game
engine or like unit or um
blender or any 3d program really so
that is uh what's up yeah you guys can
say hello youtube so
it's been so long you know um i do want
to mention quickly that
i stream a lot of my development for
both hazel dev and
and this game engine series version of
hazel live on twitch.tv slash the churno
that's why i'm streaming this right now
but also um you know as as this series
gets more complex
as we kind of begin to uh i guess go
deeper into this game engine and
obviously it's going to get to a point
where
it's going to be harder and harder to
actually
i guess um you know work out the code
that needs to be written and solve these
problems
this this series is not going to contain
me
trying to work out problems right this
series will be me kind of
showing you the solutions that i come up
with obviously
and how i solve those problems the
process of solving the problems
mostly i stream live on twitch so if
you're interested more
in seeing how i even come up with these
things or how i decide how to implement
certain features then
following along with my twitch live
stream and looking at past broadcasts or
supporting me on patreon so that you can
get access to the whole library of past
broadcasts it's probably a better
like a good thing for you to do um
essentially because it'll obviously
showcase a lot more of kind of uh
leading up to the solutions instead of
just
presenting those solutions in their
final form which is kind of what this is
about
um so uh that's
that's kind of my little disclaimer out
of the way and today let's talk about
how to actually get gizmos in and i'll
show you
basically what i've done and this is
going to be the result of what i've
spent the last couple live streams uh
thinking about and implementing so if we
take a look at what we've got so far
um there were some uh pull requests that
did make it in
i'm not gonna discuss them today some of
them are not that great and we'll
we might talk about them later i'm going
to have to reverse some stuff but it
doesn't matter
um for now what we've got is basically
this hazelnut editor
and if i try and open um a scene here
we've got like this
3d example and the reason it's called a
3d example is because the camera i think
is a perspective projection camera
um what i've added right and copied and
pasted
is this pink cube.hazelfile i'll commit
this at the end of this episode so you
guys will also be able to see it
but basically pink cube.hazel is this
lovely little pink cube that i made
during a live stream and i think this
was actually while i was planning
serialization
before i actually recorded those
episodes so definitely um
you know take a look at that and pull
the latest code so you can see this
stuff
um and this is kind of going to be our
starting point for
gizmos just because this is going to be
able to showcase it a lot more so
basically what i want to do today is i
want to be able to
uh select top right and left you know
camera doesn't really matter too much
but as i click on these entities right
i want to be able to uh you know bring
up a gizmo
around the origin of where that entity
is like pivot point at least is where
that transform is essentially in 3d
space which doesn't have to be exactly
in the middle of all the vertices
obviously because the vertices can be
completely offset
but wherever that transform is which in
this case is in this world space
position
i want to have a gizmo pop-up obviously
i want to have translation
rotation and scale so that i can modify
the translation rotation and scale
using an on-screen gizmo as i select
these now we're not going to be doing
mouse picking today that's a completely
different story has nothing to do with
gizmos
um today is just going to be all about
gizmos so how do we do this well
you could write your own gizmo library
i'm not going to do that
um i actually had a bit of a rant on
this live stream earlier today
about using third-party libraries and
how i
not necessarily how i decide which ones
to use but
you know what i think about the whole
process of using
third-party libraries um tarek thank you
so much
for your prime subscription does that
still that doesn't show up on the screen
does it i'm sorry it should um
it's just i guess because there's no
chat maybe anyway whatever sorry we'll
fix that for the next episode
tara shout out to you um anyway so uh
what was i saying yeah so um you know
regarding like third party libraries and
all of that
um we'll we'll save that for a different
day but ultimately uh i'm gonna use a
third party library called i'm wismo
which basically integrates really well
with i am gui
to actually render these gizmos now the
default look
and feel and usability and the way that
that library works
is not um perfect i think well at least
for for what i want and for what i would
like gizmos to be like in hazelnut
and in hazel um excuse me
they uh like it it doesn't it doesn't
like i've made some modifications to it
basically to make it a little bit
better in my opinion so uh what i've
done is i've forked it
um this is the fork and as usual we're
just going to add it as a sub module
i've forked it i've
uh i have not added um
[Music]
pre-make to this right but i have forked
it and if you look at i guess these
latest
like this latest comment you can see
i've just tweaked a few things here
just to make it look and feel a little
bit better um
so that uh and i don't know like this
might need some revision or whatever but
i've just changed the look and feel of
it a little bit better
um because i think it looks a bit nicer
and i've changed the tweet tweaked the
colors and just minor
editions but mostly it's just the
imprisonment stuff and this is just
something that's been in hazel there for
a while so we're going to be using that
existing code
so the first step is going to be to
actually add this as a sub module so i'm
going to go into
the root of my repository here
and i'm going to as usual just do git
sub module
add and we're going to add that now i
never remember the path of it i guess
the path comes after that
um but basically hazel and vender and
then i guess just i'm guilty right
i'm quizmo so hazel van der and i think
i can just
not type in a path i do sometimes you
have to
sometimes you don't um like that
there you go
so we've added a sub module um and again
i'm not going to compile this as a
separate module i'm just going to
compile it into hazel
because i don't know like in my opinion
i think it's it's like
realistically i think it's like two um
files so what like i just don't think
that's worth
making like a static library out of so
what i want to do um and i'll be
referring to like my diff of what i've
already worked out during the live
streams for all this stuff just to speed
this process up otherwise this episode
would be
probably a couple hours long um so what
i'll do
is i will
um find the uh
inside hazel let's find the pre-mag file
um and i'll see what i've done here so
basically all i've done is to the
compilation here
just like we we did with glm i mean this
isn't really to the compilation it's
more like to the project
i'm going to do the same thing here but
add the i am gizmo stuff so
i am gizmo was the directory
um and then i think there's again as i
mentioned two files there's the header
file
and there's a cpp file no need to add
the examples or anything like that
even though they're included we can just
keep them still there for reference code
but we don't need to compile them
so we'll just add i'm gizmo like that
and then
as far as the include directories go i'm
going to specify
um the include directory and i think the
include directory
we usually specify like the list of them
here right so when we have all of the
include directories in the premade file
that is inside our
the root of our project i'm going to add
this so we're going to do hazel vendor
um i am guizmo and i believe
um that's it i think it's just there
there's no include directory right
so that's kind of it i guess we've
included these and then finally
uh in order to be able to use this we'll
also add on gizmo
as an include directory um and then
finally the last thing i want to do that
will stop
um uh well it'll enable us to actually
not modify
uh the files themselves is we have to
deal with our pre-compiled headers
because obviously every cpp file that is
marked as using pre-compiled headers has
to
include the pre-compiled header as the
first include i'm gizmo is not our code
technically i mean i've modified it so i
could have added the include but i don't
want to
so what because it's not going to be
using any of hazel's code anyways it's
like a separate module
so what i'm going to do is
probably over here i'm going to add a
little filter
specifically for a file so you can do
files
vendor i am guizmo and then basically
any cpp file in that directory or any
subdirectory
so i've added that filter and then what
that's going to do is i'm going to
create a flag that is called no pch
that will mark the file as not using pch
right
so in other words if you go to like a
maybe that's a bad example because that
is the pch but
if you go to like this for example and
you look at the
pre-compiled header you can see this is
marked as use
not using pre-compiled headers right is
what that will do in visual studio
only for that file or only for any cpp
files there so
therefore we're going to compile without
any any issue
that's it i think so if we go into
scripts and we rerun
the generate project script and reload
it should be able to see
um i'm wismo
and we'll control f7 just to test that
out
uh it should work okay so there we go
we've now got i'm gizmo
i don't know i'm guizmo i'm gizmo
whatever we've got our gizmos
so we're going to go into the i'm gui
layer now and talk about how we can
actually render them
and how we can use them api is very
simple i really like the library by the
way
um i mean like as i men i i may have
been harsh with my oh i fixed some
things in it i didn't really fix things
i just changed the style
to suit me more and to see what i what i
wanted to look like more
but props to the author because i think
it's a great library it's
quite well written um and it does a lot
of math stuff that i would not want to
be scratching my head over
for sure okay so inside i'm gooey layer
i'm going to include i am guizmo because
we basically have to call something at
the beginning of each frame
um after we start the imgui new frame
what i want to do
is call which is actually here i want to
call i'm quizmo begin frame
because again it taps into imgui code
which is great because it's part of like
our ui which is the gizmo so it should
be
i don't want to be i don't want to like
you know um
it's really nice to have it tie into i
am gooey's draw list and all that stuff
like that's really nice because
it just ends up being part of our ui
pass instead of being like some kind of
separate opengl rendering thing so i
quite like that
also means it's quite efficient because
i'm going obviously batches everything
together
and it is rather efficient um so now
that we've done that
right all we have to do is basically use
the gizmo now
um so if we go back to our editor layer
which of course is like our layer where
we draw the viewport and do all of the
fun stuff
what i want to do is um actually start
drawing the gizmo
so if we go over here to our viewport
code and it's probably worth bringing
out maybe some of the viewport stuff
because this is going to be quite
annoying but basically before we end
because we obviously want to draw it in
the viewport
um we're going to do our gizmo stuff
here so i'll just have a little comment
called gizmos
zoom in a little bit how's chat doing
everything fine
yeah that's good sweet sometimes i like
to check in on chat a bit
because when i get when i start
recording these
these episodes i just get lost in my own
little world as if i'm recording a video
i'm not even live streaming but i am
live streaming
so the the important thing for us now is
to select an entity right like we want
to know what is the currently selected
entity
because obviously that entity's
transform is what we're trying to
control
so how do we get the currently selected
entity um and i'll just call this
selected entity well
that's where our api falls apart because
at the moment
we basically need to ask the scene
hierarchy panel hey
what is your selected entity now whether
or not that should be like that
is debatable because in the future when
you
for example mouse pick to select
entities that doesn't really involve the
scene hierarchy panel you need to
tell the scene hierarchy panel hey i've
selected this entity so please
display its properties selected in the
tree all of that stuff
but at the moment our only source of
selection that exists in this whole
thing
is inside the scene hierarchy panel so
i'm adding this here um the way it works
in hazel dev is there's basically a
series of callbacks right so every time
you select something in scene hierarchy
panel you can kind of
subscribe to that event and receive a
callback when the selection changed
because it was kind of like an
unselection changed event and then vice
versa as well you can tell the scene
hierarchy panel hey
i selected this entity so it always
should work both ways because there's
obviously going to be cases
for both of these things to work
this is annoying this is probably
another pull request
i might deal with that later okay so um
and this is really easy because we have
a selection context so really all this
becomes
is entity get selected and here i'll
make this a const function
and we would return that and thank you
visual studio okay
so that's done now we have this get
selected entity function we know what
we've currently selected
now rule number one is is anything
selected
so obviously we can just check that with
a simple if statement
is this a valid entity or is it not
right so if it's a valid entity so
it exists it's not zero it's not it's
not like no entity
we can actually start setting this up
for drawing so
um in terms of i'm gizmo we basically
need to set orthographic to false
we will be setting this to true in the
future for orthographic projections the
first step and what we're going to do
today is make it work for perspective
projections
just because it's a little bit easier to
know what we even want to do in the
first place
and let's also obviously include i am
gizmo
i am whiz more
you're happy no you're not you know why
because
this is hazelnut so let's go back to
pre-make
um and add this as an include directory
into excuse me into
hazelnuts pre-make file
i don't even know if that was like in
the diff i didn't
don't think i noticed that there you go
so it's not completely scripted
um all right so uh now we should be good
um unfortunately it's reloaded
everything so i don't know where i am
here i am
i set all the graphic to false and then
we'll do i am quizmo
set draw list right um which
i think uh you know you just call it
before manipulate to draw gizmo to that
window
that's it and then um we need to set
basically like the viewport
so set rect and this is where things are
going to get interesting so
we want to basically get from from i'm
gui
get the window position
i'm not 100 sure what the best way to do
this um because i don't know
like apparently in my diff i've written
it as get window position
[Music]
y and then i've also got the window
height so
window uh window width
is i'm going to get window width
but like i've used get available content
area before or get
available content region or whatever it
is and i'm gooey sometimes the api if
i'm going can be a little bit
all over the place just because they
seem to have a bunch of functions that
do the same thing but maybe they don't
maybe they include padding
maybe they include like little title
bars so i'm not sure like this this
not guaranteeing this to be perfect
but it should be okay for now so we're
setting the rectangle now this is like
excuse me coughing a lot today um
setting the uh
like the the viewport in a way um and
then we need to
um basically draw like the gizmo and to
do that we need to
basically work out like where the camera
is right because obviously the camera is
going to define
how we render this let's we have to set
the view projection matrix basically
um and then also get the transform from
the entity which is kind of the easy
part now the camera
part that's where that's where it's a
bit tricky
at the moment we don't have a camera and
we don't have an edited camera we've
only got like a runtime style camera
which is really a camera component
right on an entity so we need a way to
get the active camera right so what i
did
um for this is i basically was able to
retrieve the camera entity
by adding a function to our scene so to
our currently active scene
and i called it get primary camera
entity
which might seem a bit dogecoin
and uh i don't blame you if you think
that but
um i don't think it's that bad um
basically this is a bit of a convenience
function to just be like hey
get me the primary camera um and
specifically the entity that the primary
camera is attached to
so the way that that's implemented
is quite simple we just simply
uh create a view so registry view
uh with our camera component
and then we cycle through the view
because remember we're not just looking
for the camera we're looking for
the active camera for the primary camera
because we can have more than one camera
in the scene but only one obviously
um is being rendered at once so we'll
we'll iterate through that we'll
retrieve the camera
um which is actually like uh actually no
this is the um camera component
for the current entity so let's maybe
make that a reference
const reference maybe um and then if
primary is set to true we'll just
full-on just return it so we'll have to
construct a hazel entity out of it which
as we know is just the entity id and the
current pointed to the scene which is
our context
otherwise we'll return just an empty
entity that's it easy
so now if we go back to editor layer we
should be able to get the primary camera
entity which of course
is uh the case so next step
um so this is trying to get our camera
um the next step is going to be
to uh well let's get the camera
component from this
right so now that we've got the entity
let's get the camera from it so get
component camera
components i hope our camera has
everything we need by the way i haven't
really checked but basically what we
should
want we what we want to get is the
camera view matrix
um because that's what the trend that's
well no actually
the camera view is going to be the
tran the inverse transform of the camera
so the invert the transform components
transform the inverse of that um so
actually this is going to be glm inverse
uh camera entity
dot get component transform component
uh get transformed speaking of which i
think there was one thing that i wanted
to adjust here at the moment we're kind
of
um actually creating the matrix like
that
right um but i think there's a better
way to do it an easier way to do it
with the api because i
i changed it to that so i think all you
really have to do for rotation instead
of
doing this is just do glm
to mat four from the quaternion i think
and you can create a quaternion from
those euler angles like that
so that just looks a bit cleaner right
there's our rotation um and i think
for that we we do need to um
include some maybe this wasn't a better
solution but we'll need them anyway so
we'll include
the experimental stuff um
because we'll be including something
from gtx which is like the experimental
stuff so glm gtx plutonium
quaternions are experimental so i mean
you know it doesn't really mean it's
like dodgy or anything
um okay done
so next step um is
uh now that we've that was just a bit of
a
side thing but anyway we've got the
camera view the camera projection though
we should be able to pull out from there
and i think that's just going to be
camera get projection
um which doesn't exist so see this is
what i mean i might have to
ah actually nah it does exist good
might as well get the camera here that
just avoids this
so glm matt4 and is that a
what does that return a const okay sure
so cons reference
camera projection so we've got the
camera projection
we've got the camera view right
so now we've got everything we need
basically to render
so let's get the entity transform now
so from the selected entity
selected entity we can get the
transform component
um and
i guess we'll just do glm not for
uh transform equals tc dot get transform
okay so that's using the function that
we just basically modified a little bit
to add the quaternion map for thing all
right
hopefully that's not slower than than
the code we replaced but
it looks cleaner so that's why i went
for it
okay so now i mean there's some other
stuff that i've got here that will add
later like snapping but
um you know for now we'll just do i'm
gizmo
manipulate so basically long story short
we set the autograph to false because
well
you don't need to do this every frame i
don't think but um we're doing it
because we might
alternate between orthographic and
perspective based on the camera
obviously
we set the draw list so that it draws
the current window we set the rectangle
that's our viewport and then we call
manipulate this is just us getting the
data we need
for the manipulate function which is
what actually is going to deal and
render our
deal with i was going to say and render
our um gizmo so we want to do
glm value pointer the first parameters
you saw was the view
so we'll pass in camera view we're just
doing value pointer because this wants a
float pointer
then we will do the same thing for the
camera's projection
so camera projection right
then the next step is the operation okay
so for now
we're just going to do i am gizmo
operation it's just to translate
okay but we will obviously um keep track
of this and we'll be able to
switch this up to um you know rotating
scale based on like a hotkey
so the mode uh local is pretty much all
we're going to do for now
we want to be in local space um
and then the matrix is going to be the
whatever we're
trying to transform right so our
transform matrix so we'll just pass in
transform um after that
uh we've got a bunch of other stuff like
the delta matrix which we don't really
need for this
and uh snapping which we'll leave off as
well
that's it okay so if this
if something changes here where what
we're going to have to do
right is reconstruct this matrix now so
we've
obviously inside our component we store
these separately
so we convert into a matrix i'm quizmo
manipulates it and then we need to
decompose it
back into the individual um
deconstructed matrix thing so translator
rotate and scale so we'll do that in a
minute let's just see if this
renders anything that would be nice how
streamed
doing just talking about other stuff
that's cool
um okay so let's go to our pink cube
and it's already failed um
oh that's because this was wrong um so
if you actually look at this um i think
that
this should have been zero and this
should have been was it 45
i don't remember what it's supposed to
be oh and this should be zero no
how do i get it to be oh maybe they both
are 45
or something like that i don't remember
i'm trying to hack this
um oh there we go 19 45. there we go so
it's just because our rotations were in
the wrong order before so let me save
this
as the pink cube why don't we have a
normal save
anyway whatever so now you can see
beautifully right whatever i select
we see a beautiful gizmo right top
camera camera you can't really see it
because
we are the camera that's what we're
looking through um now right
oh that's a that was a bad move
you didn't see that we'll deal with that
later um
[Music]
uh so
yeah whatever we select we see a
transform and more most importantly you
can see it's at the
origin of this mesh right
of this um actually it's a sprite but
it's like
you know it's a vertex it's a
piece of geometry right it's at the
center because we know that our
coordinates are from negative 0.5 to
positive 0.5 so this
should be in the middle um and obviously
the camera's projection and everything
is working properly because we see it in
the right place
now if we try and move it it's not going
to move anywhere because we're not doing
anything yet right
that's where the next step comes in so
let's do translation first because it's
easy
so technically this whole thing is easy
right because once we've got this this
transform
matrix has been modified so we can just
do a little check first because remember
this runs every frame
this manipulate function doesn't just
manipulate our
transform it also renders it so we need
to know whether or not it's actually
been used because otherwise we don't
want to be continually decomposing and
setting our matrices
and all of our transforms if nothing's
changed so
there's a nice little is using function
and if
using is true that's when we want to
apply the changes so
what we'll do is well for this this is
the easy case right
for our translation this is as simple as
just um getting from the transform
right uh the last column
and it's going to be a back four can i
just cast that to effect three
probably like is there a constructor
that takes that in
maybe maybe i can just do that we'll see
if that works
yep okay so now you saw that was really
easy
obviously keep stressing that um
magic right look at that everything
works right
our trend well not everything but
translation works perfectly fine i can
move this wherever i like let's maximize
this make sure
it still works it does i can move this
wherever i like select something else
move this wherever i like and you can
see that it works beautifully
right that's exactly what we want to see
and then the left one as well
right okay great so that obviously works
um
now how do we do it with a rotation
scale well different ball game
a little bit more complicated than just
this so scale is easy
scale is just the length of the
diagonals um length of those vectors
um so that's pretty easy but then
we have rotation which is a bit
harder now the thing is glm actually has
a function called decompose
which takes in a matrix and gives you a
whole bunch of stuff and i mean
a whole bunch of stuff right it gives
you the scale
the orientation the translation that's
what we're after right
but then also the skew and the
perspective which we're not after
and furthermore if you look at this
function which i did during the live
stream
there's like to do fix me and i notice
that sometimes this just returns false
which means none of this actually works
not to mention that it does a whole
bunch of stuff like tries to figure out
figure out the perspective
and you know runs like inverse functions
and does a whole bunch of expensive
stuff that we don't care about
so i took the liberty of
copying this function and stripping out
everything that i don't care about
and just keeping the stuff that i want
so i got rid of skew and i got rid of
scale and i also changed
the quaternion orientation which is this
code to just be
their kind of commented out euler angle
one because that's at the end of the day
at the end of the day what we need
anyway so if i use this version i would
have had to have converted into oil
angles anyway
right and uh i came up with my own
little decomposed function
which i'm going to copy and paste and
then kind of go through roughly because
i'm not going to type it out for you
but if we go into hazel make sure we're
in show all files mode
inside source hazel i'm going to add
a little folder called math
and inside there i'm going to add a
header file
also called math and this is just kind
of generic because we don't really have
a math library
we'll include uh no i've ruined
everything
i'm gonna reshoot the whole episode um
so this is just gonna be a bunch of math
functions basically and we could hide
this by
math name space or something like that i
don't really
care maybe i do hazelmouth maybe
maybe because it's not i'm i'm not
planning to put this i didn't do this
during the live stream but maybe i'll
add a little math
name space um just to hide it behind
that um
but basically this is going to return
the same thing as the glm one
i'm just going to call it decompose
transform right because it's not going
to do anything with perspective or
you know anything like that it's just
going to be translation rotation scale
which is a transform
so i'll take in a glm.4 transform
and i will take in a vec3 uh
translation and this is what we're
outputting this is like our out
translation i guess i'll call it that
just to be
completely um
obvious rotation slash orientation
kind of the same thing in this case and
scale out
scale so that's kind of what it looks
like
um nice big function and then we're
going to implement it in a cpp file
so let's grab this math.cpp
include our pch include math
namespace hazel math i guess i'll do
that
um uh and then we'll copy and paste it
from my diff
so let's grab that
all right
um i left this in here because i'm not
sure if we ever need this
um and it didn't bother actually working
out but we'll do this here
so you need to include the whole matrix
decompose thing also which is this
let's talk about this briefly so what
did i do well i left a comment saying
what it's from just in case someone
needs to fix it or change it
um i added using namespace glm so
because in their code it assumes that
and i didn't want to add glm everywhere
inside this function and also
did using t equals float because
originally it is a template function
um which runs i guess for like a
different amount
of um different data type or different
um i don't know like it's it's just it's
it's templated
but we don't really need that so i just
kind of added a using t equals float
here because we're going to be using it
with floats
just so that i wouldn't have to replace
t absolutely everywhere as you can see
in this function
but ultimately i just stripped the stuff
i didn't need and as i mentioned
uncommented out this rotation code
that's it really simple
um and it should be a lot faster than
their matrix decompose as well
because obviously um
obviously uh theirs does a lot more and
it's not cheap some of the stuff that it
does so yeah
anyway that's that so now in editor
layout
i will include hazel math
math right and the idea here is instead
of using
uh this translation like this we could
do that but we'll be a bit more obvious
we'll do
um uh math decompose transform so it's
hazel's math
function now transform will be the
transform and then we have
glm vect3 translation
rotation scale translation
rotation scale now by default these
won't be initialized obviously so just
keep an eye on that
um but this should set all of them as
far as i'm aware because the only it
might return here in which case it
doesn't set all of them but otherwise it
doesn't return
whereas the glam one returned in a bunch
of places and that actually
um had me stumped a few times anyway so
now we set translation to this
translation which again is the same it's
just more of a convenience thing
but we also have rotation and scale now
here's the thing with rotation
um if you don't if you just get the
rotation from the matrix you can easily
wind up with gimbal lock
really easy way to fix that as far as
i'm concerned um
is to just apply rotation as a delta
right so instead of apply because that
that way you're always just adding
something you're never gonna wind up um
with
uh something being locked because of
like an equation because you're always
just adding an angle
so to do that um we basically need to
store the
original rotation um
which is easy because our transform
component already has it
right so when we get our transform
component in here right we can just do
glm
vect3 original rotation
equals tc dot rotation easy right and in
fact
if you really wanted to i guess you
could do it here because the transform
component hasn't been set here and then
we can do actually we can just do delta
rotation
which is going to be our decomposed
rotation minus the transform component's
original rotation that's our delta
rotation and then
we can just say rotation plus equals
that delta okay
this is perfect no gimbal lock no
nothing everything will work as expected
okay
finally scale tc dot scale equals scale
and that's it that is our whole gizmo
situation now the only thing i would
love to do is be able to change
what gizmo is currently active so let's
see how we can do that
now this stuff um honestly we could
store this as just an
ant i guess so if i go over here um
and i'll do int gizmo
type equals negative one which means no
gizmo right because
translate is zero rotate and is one
scale is
two and there's also this bouncing which
we're not using uh which is three but um
if we just replace this with i am gizmo
type and we cast this to an i'm gizmo
operation we can also have that kind of
nun
type which is negative one so um we only
want to draw the gizmo if the selected
entity exists
and gizmo type does not equal negative
one right
so if it's actually a gizmo let's let's
draw it right
so the cool thing here is that if i now
want to
um you know look at the rotation gizmo
which i think is number one right
well actually what i should do is
actually use the enum
so rotate
let's see if that works
i should probably just have it load the
cube by default
there's our rotation gizmo should be
able to rotate stuff now and you can see
i can
um and everything seems to work
perfectly and you can watch the rotation
obviously over here change
now you might notice something um if
you're um
looking closely here these never go past
the kind of negative 180 to positive 180
range the reason is that with a rotation
obviously
zero degrees is the same as 360. it's
the same as 720
etc right you kind of have this
situation where
to solve a rotation equation obviously
like there are multiple solutions
um and uh i mean hopefully that makes
sense right
so um a lot of a lot of engines and
3d programs like i think blender unreal
and unity all
have this kind of concept of a rotation
that is past
that range so you can have a rotation of
a thousand degrees
actually show up here and it will make
sense and you can see that technically
speaking if we do this ourselves using
this
it's gonna work because at the end of
the day remember this is just a vec3
right so you can see we have a thousand
degrees but what happens now if i start
rotating this
well technically this is equal to about
well that was equal to like about zero
degrees or whatever
but you can see in general that um this
is this
also is the same as that minus 360
degrees minus 360 minus three whatever
so if i start rotating it now and you
watch this value here right
this all works as as expected you can
see nothing weird happens with the
rendering
but suddenly this is snapped down to 25.
now whether or not you want to keep it
this way
is i think up to you and your engine
i think this is fine because fixing this
problem as far as i'm aware is kind of
a complex issue and i was not able to
come up with an easy
straightforward solution i think this
what i've written here is quite
straightforward
um so i'm going to leave it as is for
now programmatically doesn't matter
because that rotation is going to be
identical to all those others and you
can see that i can
you know this does not stop me from
you know interacting with everything
else as usual it just finds another
solution usually one that's inside that
unit circle
so um therefore i would say it's fine
programmatically if you want to increase
this like just have something that
increases the angle by
one degree every frame or 10 degrees
every frame it's not like you have to
check to make sure that if it's above
180 set it to negative 180 otherwise
everything will break
it's not going to break you can see
right um
go.engine i noticed also does this
they don't go past 180 degrees with
gizmos and stuff like that
right um but everything else that i
could find does
and so i just chose this this kind of
solution because
it just happened to be really simple as
you saw
and everything seems to work fine okay
so that's that
um look at me trying to switch gizmos if
it works let's make that happen
eh so to switch gizmos um we should
just add a little uh you know key code
thing here
so um at the end of these things
let's add our gizmo shortcuts so i'll do
gizmos
um so case key q so q
um i kind of like these controls q w e r
so these are from like i think most 3d
programs but i remember this in like 3d
max and maya and everything really
um blend just has their own kind of you
can use g to just
move stuff without having to use gizmos
and i don't think that gives them a
shortcut the same here
but um q is kind of your selection tool
so it's just nothing
w is translate e is rotate r is scale so
it's kind of like q w e r
uh your kind of select and then trs
translate rotate and scale
so um this is as simple as just setting
the gizmo type to negative one if it's q
because that's our
selection tool that's no gizmo at all
and maybe in the future when we have
tools we'll rewrite this
um and also this maybe should be
customizable shortcuts as well but
whatever for now
um w is translate so we'll set it to i
am quizmo operation
translate um and then obviously this is
going to be rotate and scale
so scale rotate
isn't this just all really easy i love
it when programming is just as simple as
adding that stuff in a matter of seconds
you know
it's good it's always good when you
write code like that um
now uh none of this works because
i am still setting it every frame
so let's remove that
someone said that's why most engines use
radians i'm using radians as well has
nothing to do with radians radians are
just a different
a different unit it's kind of like
meters versus centimeters
right or i guess celsius and fahrenheit
also that's a bit different there's a
direct conversion between
an easy conversion i'll say between
radians and not radians it's the same
thing it's just a different unit
um we're storing everything in radians
we're only converting to degrees
for uh for this view here
so if i look at um
[Music]
pink cube that took me too long um this
view here is in degrees but internally
it's all storing this in radians like if
i uh
look at i guess this is fine where's my
transform component here
you can see that the rotation for the
selected entity is 0.78
that's equivalent to 45 degrees i think
um
so uh it is actually in radians right
it's this one here
45 degrees okay anyway um
yeah so now right q you can see gets rid
of the gizmo entirely w
r beautiful let's test out scale works
perfectly fine
we should be able to move this somewhere
now let's move it over here
um we can rotate it wherever we want we
can
scale it non-uniformly
everything seems to be fine right
uh we can scale it to zero and
everything's fine doesn't break
um and then scaling it up will take a
little bit of time but there we go
right everything seems to work so um
you guys can play with this and try and
break it and then we can fix any bugs
that come out of it but
for the time being as you can see i
think i'm pretty happy with it
now the last thing that we're going to
add this is a long episode isn't it we
haven't had one in 43 minutes okay good
i'm happy this is this makes up for like
the fact that we haven't
a big juicy episode makes fact makes up
for the fact that we haven't done an
episode in ages
um but uh the last thing that i'm going
to do
is uh add snapping to this right so if i
hold the control key down
i want to basically snap to angles of 45
degrees
or like to maybe 0.5 meters if i'm
translating or scaling
now pretty easy to do this should be
configurable in the ui maybe you don't
want to snap to 45 degrees maybe you
want to snap to half of that maybe you
want to snap to 90 degrees i don't know
um it's totally something that you
should be able to customize i think
um so what i'll do and why do i have
this there we go this is a little hand
cursor for ages um i see every program
has
problems so don't don't be too harsh on
hazel
um so what we'll do is uh maybe over
here we'll we'll deal with snapping
so i'll first of all whether or not
we're snapping it's going to directly
uh depend on whether or not at the time
of us rendering the gizmo
is key pressed um and we'll just say the
control key i think left control
right so that's if snapping is enabled
or not
now the snap value that's what you want
to snap to we'll set to 0.5
however totally going to depend on the
tool
right so 0.5 might be good for
translation and
scale but for rotate 0.5 degrees
bit silly right so what we'll do is
we'll say
um i could write this as like a ternary
you know but this will probably be
easier um if
uh m gizmo type equals
i am gizmo operation rotate
snap value equals 45
snap to 45 degrees for rotation
snap to 0.5 meters
for translation so um hazel uses meters
for
units in case that's not already clear
um
[Music]
i think most game engines probably do um
okay so we have a snap value beautiful
now we actually need to create like a
little um float array out of it so that
we can do it for x y and z
because you can actually i'm gizmo lets
you set a different snap um
value for each uh axis but that's
probably not that um useful most of the
time
so snap values and then we'll just do
snap value snap value
snap value because that's what i am
going to wants
and then we just um pass
in snap values into manipulate if we
need them
so this i think is a delta matrix which
we'll leave at
uh null pointer and then if we're using
snap we'll pass in our snap values
otherwise we'll pass a null pointer and
that should in fact be our snap
argument and it is all right so
hopefully now if we hold the left
control key down we will snap now
obviously this will snap based on where
you currently are
it's not gonna just it's not gonna be
like a world snap maybe that'll be a
good feature as well
but ultimately what this means is that
if i'm at 0.6
and i try to translate with snapping
it'll move me to 1.1
not to 1 or to 0.5
so if i select like this one and i move
and then i hold ctrl
a you can see that i now snap to place
and you can see over here that i'm at
0.35 x and if i
uh hold ctrl and by the way you can
start moving but then halfway through
hold ctrl which i really like because
you can see that's perfect
and you can see that this is all is a
one by one quad so one by one meters
which means if i do
two increments with snapping on i'm
perfectly at this edge and you can see
the math here work out
perfectly might be uh slightly incorrect
or whatever no actually i don't think it
was that it was
this is this is displaying to that
because you can see that's a bit off now
this was displaying to two decimal
places which was not um
which is not obviously that accurate as
accurate as what it actually is
uh because i think if i load that again
and we look at
this one well it's still explained to
two decimal places here anyway whatever
i give up
anyway there we go that works and with
rotation again if i start rotating hold
down control
there's your 45 degree increments and
you can see the degrees drop here
even throws it up in radians as well
which is nice all right
beautiful so we've got snapping what
more could you want perfect right
so there you go that is that is gizmos
implemented what do you think
chat stream you happy um let's bring the
let's bring the chat in um ah
the chat's gone i deleted it that's
that's a bit um unsettling it's back
though
all right so that is that's that right
it's really not that difficult when
you're using a third-party library
that you have already modified to uh
look nice and to
you know to work like you want to and
you've spent the time to work this stuff
out
and you have your own decompose function
and everything else has already been
done for you it's pretty easy
um but that's basically it um i
i'm gonna quickly look through the diff
to see if i missed anything oh yeah
one thing that is really annoying that i
noticed is that
basically the way this is set up at the
moment is that if i um well first of all
let's just try and activate a gizmo here
okay
doesn't matter it's not gonna crash or
anything which is good if i load pink
cube
um this is really annoying i'm the right
gizmo here
right i've clicked on left to select it
e r doesn't work even when i'm hovering
over the viewport wei doesn't work until
like click
and then it works now this is already a
problem because when we have mouse
picking
we can't just click arbitrarily on the
viewport because that's also going to
probably do a raycast and pick an object
so that's super annoying um and the
reason this happens is because
i'm a fool who accidentally
doesn't understand how logic works and
wrote
this little piece of code here so when
we block events i did viewport focused
all of you but hoverboard is both files
what we want is to only block advance if
neither viewport focus nor viewport
hovered is true
so in other words if you're neither
focused on the viewport
nor are you hovering over it so actually
this should be and
because what we're looking here for here
is we want this to be false if either of
these are true
and obviously they have to both be true
for this to be true and thus
block events is true so yeah a little
bit sometimes they can be a little bit
annoying these things
um okay so now if i do this basically
it's a really really subtle thing
but now the cool thing is if i do this
right w
e r not working because i'm hovering
over scene hierarchy but as soon as i
don't have to click on it as soon as i
hover there you go see it immediately
gets set as long as i'm over the
viewport i think that's how blender
works as well
um but you can decide how you want to do
this yourself um
in hazel there we have something a bit
more sophisticated because i think that
if like you're maybe typing the name
here
but you're hovering over here you can
see it still changes
um and you can actually fix this by
seeing if i'm gui has
the focus of a particular control we're
not going to cover that today hazeldev
does that though
um but yeah otherwise there you go
gizmos knock yourself out um
uh yeah they'll always be dependent on i
think the size of the screen
so you can see they're kind of kind of
small here but you're not really going
to be doing
that and then here they get kind of big
so they're kind of in the screen space
size i guess
um but yeah that is your whole gizmo
situation and as you can see everything
seems to work pretty well
and that is gizmos so hope you guys
enjoyed
this video if you did please do not
forget to hit
the like button or subscribe on twitch
um patreon.com is the best way to help
support
this series and also get access to the
hazel dev code which
is really exciting take a look at the
latest hazel devlog i'll have it linked
up there as well
um we've got like shadows now and i'm
working on some other really exciting
stuff that i can't wait to reveal so
everything's going really well doing
tons of work on this we've got a
wonderful community of people and i'm so
happy with everything
that we have been able to achieve and
thank you so much to all of you for your
support and
make just helping to make all this
possible it's just amazing
all right next time what i don't even
know what we're gonna do next time i
never know because we've done
like this now oh we should look at the
road map we'll look at the road map at
the beginning of next episode and decide
what we're doing
don't forget to follow on twitch as well
if you want to catch the latest live
streams and twitter as well because i
usually announce live streams there
i will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you